[Musique]
bienvenue à citer démocrate
la rentrée politique du mouvement
démocrate
vous le savez les universités de rentrée
ont été inventés il ya longtemps par les
jeunes jerry this gardiens et les jeunes
centristes et notamment par marielle de
sarnez à qui j'adresse un salut amical
et affectueux et cette année pour la
première fois vous avez rendez vous en
ligne sur le site internet sur les
réseaux sociaux du modem
tout au long du week end pour échanger
débattre interagir avec nos intervenants
au programme de nos travaux des tables
rondes qui associeront les responsables
nationaux les membres du gouvernement
les parlementaires les élus du modem des
forums des parlementaires européens
le forum des députés et des sénateurs le
forum des démocrates pour la planète des
vidéos préparé par les jeunes démocrates
et par l'équipe d'université 133 le
chantier de réflexion long cours que
nous avons lancée l'année dernière à
guidel les discours de clôture du
premier ministre et de françois bayrou
président du modem maire de pau haut
commissaire au plan avec lequel vous
pourrez aussi échanger sans filtre dès
cet après midi à 17h30
nous allons parler ensemble des grands
enjeux qui sont devant nous des grandes
questions la reconquête des territoires
la revitalisation de nos institutions de
notre vie démocratique
l'avenir et la place de l'ordre dans le
monde
la nécessaire conciliation entre
l'urgence économique et le développement
durable
le renforcement des solidarités à tous
les âges de la vie
sans oublier bien sûr les échéances
électorales du mois de mars 2021
quel le modem auquel vous aurez toutes
vos cartes en votre nom à toutes et tous
au nom de françois bayrou je voudrais
remercier évidemment l'équipe des
permanents du modem qui a travaillé
d'arrache-pied depuis des semaines pour
nous permettre de nous retrouver ce
week-end dans le contexte très
particulier que nous vivons et j'associe
à ces remerciements
l'équipe technique qui nous permet ces
moments d'interaction en ligne et bien
évidemment les nombreux bénévoles qui
sont mobilisés tout le week-end pour
faciliter nos échanges
je remercie également mes collègues
secrétaires généraux adjoints alice le
moral et richard amos pour leur
engagement sans faille lors et remercie
la cinquantaine des intervenants qui
vont être avec nous ce week end et
notamment les membres du gouvernement
qui se sont rendus disponibles malgré
une rentrée très chargée
remercié aussi l'équipe d'université 133
qui travaille depuis un an qui a
travaillé sur la consultation publique
qui a mené un grand nombre d'auditions
dont vous aurez aujourd'hui une première
restitution à travers les vidéos et puis
bien sûr les jeunes démocrates qui ont
beaucoup travaillé cet été pour préparer
un certain nombre de vidéos que vous
découvrirez également et qui sont là
présents tout le week-end sur les
réseaux sociaux pour faire vivre cette
rentrée politique alors à toutes et tous
je souhaite une excellente cité
démocrate
et maintenant place aux débats